للمزيد ينضم الينا من الدوحه المراسل فهد
الشهري وسعد مامون اليوتيوبر الجزائري
اهلا بك يا فارس يسعد صباحك همم سمعني
سعيد
سعيد صباح الخير
صباح النور اختي سهام اهلا بك طيب فهد
تسال انت السؤال وانا اكمل يعني
في الملعب ذهب سعيد بيودع الملعب ولكن
يعتقد انه راح يكون حديث همم الى نجوم
الحديث الى جانب نجوم المونديال سعيد كان
حديث الفتره الماضيه سعيد حدثنا القصه من
البدايه
ااا ايش اللي صار اتذهب تحضر المباراه بعد
المباراه بدقائق همم اسم اليوتيوبر
الجزائري مع صامولي 2
صباح الخير وصباح الخير الجماعه هناك
استديو سهام اختي وكل المشاهدين القنوات
العربيه سعيد جدا اول حضور على قناه في
الشرق الاوسط قناه العربيه اول شيء الحدث
النفس من الناس
الميدان يعني اصور فيديوهات عاديه مثل ما
اني اصور حياتي اليوميه حتى شفت فيهم
متجمعين علينا
صور قلت انا كوني انا يوتيوبر خليني اسمع
الحدث يعني بطريقه خاصه اني اتكلم فيديو
واسال عادي يعني السؤال الرياضي واللي
زايد الطين بالله مثل ما يقولون كوني انا
جزائري ممكن يتصمم لم يفهم حديثي باللغه
الانجليزيه
كانت الناس تاخذ معها الصور قلت لها بليز
عادي هو راح يمشي وانا مشيت معاها مشيت
وراه مشيت وراء ناديت بكلمه وانتو تريديري
وبعدين الفيديو اللي تم مشاهدتونا على
القنوات واللي انتشر في كل مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في قطعه وهذه القطعه فيها لغز
وقبل ما يضربني مسكني من شعري يعني مسكني
قال لي انت غبي غلي انت غبي انت غبي راح
قلت لها قلت لها تعلم انا لماذا غبي لانني
انا جزائري
سمع منك له زوجه الجزائريه
راح اسالك سؤال في ما يخص المباراه يعني
اسالك سؤال على الجزائر وعلى الكاميرا
وعلى الحكم يعني السؤال عادي يعني ساله
ممكن لم يتمكن صحفي هي المباراه اللي عشان
نضع المشاهد في همم الصوره لاهلت الكاميرا
على حساب الجزائر
شيء مدخلين الطلب ما اجتني الفرصه اتكلم
نهايتهم مباشره لانه اخلي كل العالم يعرف
انه خلص رد خلاص لان كانت اول مقابله ممكن
تكون مع شخص الجزائر
للاسف الشديد لم اتوقع
انا من عشاق برشلونه اي يوم من الايام احب
هذا اللاعب واتمنى التقط معه صوره اليوم
يضربني اعتقد لم اتوقعها لاعب كبير مثل
اذا صامويل لازم تقبل الانتقال حتى لو انا
انتقادتك انا لم انتقدها والله لم انتقد
يعني الناس حللت الناس شافت قالت مستحيل
انه رئيس الاتحاد اسطوره مثل ايتو انه
يتهجم بهالطريقه الا اكيد انه سمع كلمه
موسيقه لم ممكن اسمع كلام من الجزائريين
اما من الجزائريين يعني طاقتها كلها طلعها
علي انا للاسف الشديد حتى في تصريحه اللي
جاي قال لك تعرضت الى الكثير من الناس
تحدث علي بالاساءه بعد المباراه انت عندنا
متحدث عليه الناس اطلع بتقرير اطلع من
اطلع اطلع فيديو برا هذا الشيء
[موسيقى]
وبعدين تطلع بالاعتذار الاتحاديه
الجزائريه وليس لان شخصيا
طيب بعد الحادث يقال انه ااه سودره كاميرا
انتم تقتل الحديث بالكاميرا وثقت الحديث
ومن اول ما وصلت وحتى ان شاء الله بحول
الله حتى لطلبه مني السلطات القطري انا
مستعد بهذا الشيء وشوفوني الحديث كيف كان
اصلا فيديوهاتي كلها انا بضحك ممكن هو
يتوقفني ما يفهم العربي يتذكر ممكن انا
همم شغل نفس ما احنا نقول استفزه وانا كل
كلامي اضحك حتى لو انا ممكن ضربني وتشوفني
انا اضحك
في الفيديو يعني انا ضحكت تتكلم مع
الفيديو وافكر استهزاء وانا اتكلم باللغه
العربيه انا يا جماعه ان شاء الله اليوم
راح نسال عليها
المشجعين هناك
وانا احكي معك قلت لها
كويس
مباراه الجزائر
للاسف طبعا سهام وايضا المتابعين يعني
مهما ان يحدث من سعيده وغير سعيد انت رئيس
الاتحاد انت اسطوره انت في الملعب 45,000
اكيد انه رح تسمع الكلام اشكال انواع هذا
مو مبرر لما فعله
سهام تفضلوا فهد اخر مستجدات
ما وقع التواصل على حسابه يعتذر فيها من
سعيد هل يقبل سعيد الاعتذار وان وصلت
مستجدات القضيه خصوصا انها بين ايدي او
الشرطه القطريه
مرحبا سهام احنا الان خلصنا الحادث ننتقل
لما بعد الحادثه سعيد ما بعد الحادثه او
شيء بنبدا من الاخير لقالته سهام اعتذارته
حدثنا عن النقطه هذه
الاتحادي الجزائري ولم يكن لي انا شخصيا
هذا الاعتذار انا الصراحه ما شوف الاعتذار
ممكن اشوفها اعتذار سياسي اكثر من اللي هو
اعتداء شخصي طالما اعتذر لم ياتيني لحد
الان انا ما اقدر افرح عن اي شيء لكن
الشيء اللي يفكر فيه انا اقبل الاعتذار
ورايح في الامر القانونيه الاجراءات
القانونيه عشان ناخذ حقي هذا اللي طالب
بيه انا حقي قبل كل شيء همم
همم حقق والقانون الامر لا يغضب احد واحنا
في بلد قانون وفي المونديال سعيد ما بعد
الحادثات حدثني عن العائله الاصداء
الاصدقاء العائله الذي وصلت العائله في في
نفس اليوم انا الوالده معنا انترنت والولد
نفس الشي معنا الانترنت بس يشوف اخبار
جديده على ابنه لكن وصل الخبر في
التلفزيون باللي انا تعرضت للغرب وشاف هذا
الخبر تخيل اليوم الليل كامل الوالد ما
ينام يقول لي والله يتكلم معي يقول لي انا
والله العظيم ما نمت الوالده نفس الشيء
يقول لي انا بخير صحتي جاي تقول لا انا ما
نمت تحس الوالده سبحان الله العظيم انت
مرتاح ممكن وتمشي في امورك
مش مطمنين مش هادئين يعني سبحان الله
العظيم كل الناس تجيبهم كل الناس تزورهم
طمنونا عليا بصراحه انا نادر جدا على
الشيء اللي سبب هذا الشيء
بنطمن همم سعيد والد سعيد انه سعيد بخير
الحمد لله
تصير الحمد لله لكن للاسف القمر العائله
تحس صراحه اكثر نفسيا واللي خلق اكثر اكثر
الفيديو ما كنت عارف انه انتشر انا نفسي
احطه على قناتي
او اسبانيا لكن يقولون انا صاحب البرازيلي
ما اعرفها شخصيا طبعا لكن الفيديو لو كنت
اعرف انه يروح ينتشر لهذه الدرجه انا
الصراحه ممكن كنت نتجنب بطريقه هذا مش
مشكله انا اتمنى الشهره على لما شهر
بالضبط
الفيديو كنت تتوقعين انه همم
يوتيوبر جزائري او كان عندك خبر
[موسيقى]
لانه معروف لانه ما عنده شخصيه يعني الله
اعلم شو قال له السعيد
لا لا هو ما قالوا سعيد اليوم
اخت سهام هناك ناكد لك خبر هذا ممكن
الصراحه والله العظيم وانا اقولها لكن
اختي هناك في الاستديو انا لم اسب ولم
اشتم وحتى شفت ردت فعلي بعد الضرب
يا سعيد بتقول انه انت استفزيته وحكيته هو
رئيس الاتحاد الكامرون لكره القدم انت قلت
له ايش رشيت حكم مباراه الجزائر
والكاميرون
لا لا شوفي اخ سهام هناك انا شوفي نجاوبك
بكل صراحه بكل صدق السؤال اللي كانوا موجه
لم يطلع باللساني قلت له فقط راح نسالك
سؤال ممكن ايه طول عرفني في مباراه
الكاميرون اللي هي انا مره ممكن شافني
وكنت ممكن مش عارف لان شاهد مباريات
الكاميرون ومش عارف انا ما نقدر نقولها
في المباراه
على الملعب هذا اخر ملعب اخر مباراه سوف
تقام في ملعب الساعه 7:00 انا بعد ما رحت
اني هناك ما كان رئيس الاتحاد
متى الرئيس اتحاد مباراه يعني كان طالع كم
مشجع عادي كان بزين نفس ما شفته انتم ما
كان لقاء لقيته شخصيا انا الشيخ ايتو ما
شاء الله كان في يوم من الايام خذ وليد ما
اقدر اني ان تقضي اليوم
تاكد انه معك
ثلاث دقائق ان شاء الله بحول الله راح يبث
في حال لم ياتي حقي يعني راح يبث هذا ان
شاء الله
ونشكر السفير الجزائري
والقنوات كاميرا
[موسيقى]
اما الاضرار الجسديه الاطر جسديه قلت لك
انت ممكن تلحين شفني بنفسك قلت لي عندكم
مش قادر اني هذا المكان كلها سهام يعني
تناول بعض الحلويات قبل الهواء كان سعيد
والله ينبغض بصعوبه من نفس الفك هذا كله
والله مش قادر امداح في ناس فكر والله
العظيم مش قادر
بصراحه من الكابتن سيموليته لكن حقك اكيد
انه سيعود نفسي اكثر والله نفسي تشوف
تعليقات كيف الناس تسب تقول لك ضعف شخصيه
ليش ما ضرب يا جماعه اول شيء كبير في
العمر ثاني شيء صاحب منصب انا حياتي
شكرا جزيلا
الله يبارك فيك الله يحفظك ان شاء الله
شكرا على الصيام عائشه تسلم سعيد شكرا يا
فهد الشهري شكرا لكم